most people who hear of Lucifer they
think of a slithering demon coming to
get you from underground and pull you
into hell that's not what Lucifer is
Lucifer is the bearer of light it's the
Temptation it's the ego it's correlated
with our blood in the body it's the fire
it's the hyper spiritual it's the Super
Hyper religious it's being completely
disconnected from your Earth body and
connected to the fundamentals of what of
what Earth is it's being so outside of
your body and your thought that it's
becoming irrational
it's it's it's too spiritual to
comprehend that's the and you are the
Savior mentality you've seen it with a
lot of stories of people saying I'm the
Divine you know messenger you know I I
am this I am that and creating followers
and wanting to be revered as The Guiding
Light that's a luciferic tendency and
that's a Lucifer compulsion